[Musik]
ja die hells angels die lagen noch im
bett als das spezialeinsatzkommando
heute früh aus rückte um 6 uhr groß
razzia bei den rockern 30
spezialeinsatzkräfte stürmen zwei häuser
in einer villengegend in potsdam hier
sehen sie die ersten bilder mitgebracht
von unseren reportern von diesem einsatz
und einer unserer reporter die dort
waren heute früh um sechs hannes radweg
begrüßte dich eines live im moment in
potsdam was war da heute früh los bei
dieser razzia in den ganz frühen
morgenstunden
genau kurz vor 6 also im dunkeln noch
ist hier in dieser beschaulichen straße
man sieht es hinter mir hier ist also um
sechs uhr morgens überhaupt nichts los
alle menschen schlafen noch ruhig in
ihren betten denn ihren wohnungen ist
noch nicht licht angeschaltet und im
dunkeln schutze der dunkelheit ist die
polizei zu fuß dieses
spezialeinsatzkommandos aus brandenburg
sind hier zu fuß fast lautlos haben die
sich diesem gebäude hier genähert und
einem weiteren gebäude im hintergrund
der straße aber eben auch hier haben die
tür aufgebrochen und sind dann in die
oberen stockwerke wahrscheinlich auf
einer wohnung die nach hinten zum hof
rausgeht eingedrungen um dort einen
haftbefehl von der staatsanwaltschaft
frankfurt oder zu vollstrecken die
beamten haben auch einen mann in der
wohnung angetroffen und haben ihn eben
vor wenigen minuten gehen uns vorbei aus
dem haus geführt in einem funkwagen weg
gebracht wahrscheinlich zum gericht
hintergrund der ganzen sache ist die
auswertung von den coaches daten die
holländische und französische ermittler
vor knapp zwei jahren ausgewertet haben
darin geht es um drogenhandel im großen
stil die rocker der hells angels hier
aus berlin sollen eben im höheren
dreistelligen bereich kilobereich
marihuana und amphetamine gehandelt
haben und einer von den beschuldigten
soll hier hinter mir in diesem haus
wohnen
und der ist eben heute festgenommen
worden das ganze gegen sehr schnell sehr
lautlos bis auf zwei kurze knaller wurde
offensichtlich die türen geöffnet worden
haben wir hier draußen nichts gehört wir
haben uns ein bisschen zurückgehalten um
natürlich diesen einsatz auch nicht zu
gefährden das ist selbstverständlich bei
solchen aktionen das wir journalisten
zwar da sind aber uns eben auch verdeckt
halten um eben hier nicht irgendwie
genau das ganze das den erfolg dieser
razzia praktisch dieser festnahme zu
gefährden eine trafik vielen herzlichen
dank aus potsdam und wir schalten direkt
zu frank schneider er ist unser
polizeichef reporter wieder eine große
razzia und wieder hören wir das wort
enco schätzt das soll ja sozusagen das
whatsapp der unterwelt seien fragen was
genau steckt da dahinter
ja das ist genau der fall ist war ja
spektakulär im letzten jahr da wurde das
ganze bekannt da haben die holländischen
und hannes hat schon gesagt auf
französischen behörden teilweise auch
die englischen behörden eben dieses
system geknackt ausgang war eben
frankreich und das war ein handys viele
tausende die untereinander verschlüsselt
kommunizieren konnten und das hat die
polizei geschafft zu knacken und konnte
dadurch natürlich erst mal heimlich denn
die verbrecher wussten nichts davon mit
lesen hat alle daten gesichert und kann
natürlich dadurch jetzt ganz viele
verbrechen nachweisen damals war es so
und holland waren ja sogar folter
container gefunden worden da hatte man
ja befürchtungen es gäbe auftragsmordes
sind auch wirklich auftragsmorde mehr
oder weniger live verhindert worden war
die polizisten mit lesen konnten und als
dann die betreiber dieses enco
chatsystem merkens die polizei hat uns
geknackt haben sie noch eine warn sms
rausgeschickt und das system dann
abgeschaltet aber es hat ihnen nichts
genützt denn die daten sind da sie haben
eine zeit gebraucht um ausgewertet zu
werden sie müssen gerichtsfest
ausgewertet werden dh die beweise müssen
reichen es müssen beweise dazu geholt
werden aufgrund der erkenntnisse aus
engadget werden dann
telefonüberwachungen geschaltet und wenn
die ergebnisse dann so sind beweise so
ausreichend sind dass es für haftbefehle
und mutmaßlich auch für verurteilung
reicht dann rückt eben wie heute morgen
im morgengrauen das
spezialeinsatzkommando aus und holt sich
die leute und das werden wir in den
nächsten wochen und monaten immer wieder
erleben also enk rochat ist wieder das
stichwort so auch heute früh um sechs
uhr als die polizei dort zuschlag in
dieser villengegend in
potsdam und auch da gab es wieder wie
wir von hannes gerade gehört haben
festnahm was uns noch einmal zusammen
frank bitte was dieses knacken design
coaches bisher gebracht hat
das hat extrem viel gebracht wir haben
weit über 3.000 festnahmen europaweit
europol hat das ganze zusammen geführt
mittlerweile wird es bei den behörden
direkt in den ländern weiter geführt
aber die ganz grossen verfahren eben die
drohnen morde und was dort alles
passieren sollte das wurde sofort
verhindert und diese anderen
ermittlungen wie hier sind natürlich
auch schwerwiegende straftaten aber hier
geht den beamten nichts verloren die
ermittlungsergebnisse sind da die
beweise sind da der der schriftverkehr
auch eben audiodateien verschickte fotos
alles das konnte gesichert werden das
war vorher nicht möglich auch bei der
telefonüberwachung nicht und deswegen
ist es für die polizei eine wahre
goldgrube und wie gesagt es wird in den
nächsten wochen und monaten weitere die
sarrazin geben hier waren zwar wieder
rocker ist in teilweise aber auch
bereich organisierte kriminalität
arabische großfamilien clans ähnliches
die haben alle mit diesen handys
operiert wird diesen handys gearbeitet
und das ist jetzt eben für die polizei
europaweit eine wahnsinnige goldgrube um
diese täter alle zu überführen